[Music]
harrison is in louisville kentucky hey
harrison what's up
hey hey dave thank you for taking my
call sure how can we help
hey okay so uh i am engaged to be
married um my fiance and i are almost
done building our house um
so we are completely out of debt except
for the house
and we have our three to six months
saved up
and i want to start paying on the house
and just knock that out but she really
likes security and she wants to
continue to save and not pay as much on
the house and i was just kind of seeing
like what you thought about that
when are you getting married
when am i getting married um as soon as
the house is built
that's when it's being developed why'd
you pick that order
um well we kind of decided to do both of
them at the same time it's like jumping
off of it's like jumping out of an
airplane and then trying to find out
where your parachute is
so yeah
at the same time
uh yeah we
we got engaged and then started building
now
when will it be complete approximately
um
january february okay
all right
because here's the answer to your
question there's not a wii until you're
legally married
because legally there's not a way
all right okay if you die today without
a will
she's got nothing
except what's in her name
whose name is this house in
uh it's in
my name oh
okay
so she she doesn't have a house
if you die today without a will
there's an example of what i'm talking
about
your mom and daddy got a new house
if you die without a will today so
number one either go get married by uh
thanksgiving or go get a will done by
thanksgiving okay number two
um there's a wii after you're married
number three
uh no you don't need more than six
months of expenses set aside you have
zero debt except a house and you're
attacking the house and by the way a
paid for house is a greater element of
security than a larger emergency fund is
okay so she really wants security
security comes from the paid for house
um and uh
so it now the thing you may want to
investigate because one of the biggest
things we fight about in marriage is
money um
you may want to investigate what the
lack of where her insecurity comes from
that's so extreme that she violates that
she wants an extra pile of money beyond
what any financial planning
expert i mean the three to six months of
expenses is kind of a standard in the
financial planning world i didn't come
up with that
that's been out there for 50 years
and okay hardly anybody says oh have a
year just to be safe
i just never see that or hear that
because you should move on with other
things at some point rather than just
piling up cash that's making you nothing
but i would want to know you know what
what's you know is there the way she
grew up that family got foreclosed on
three times or they're always having to
move because her mom misbehaved with
money or what what is driving this
this need for an extra large umbrella
just in case it rains do you know what
that answer is
uh no i don't know what that answer is
um do you think that's a correct
question to ask
uh yeah i can definitely see why you
would ask that question and i guess i
should try to see if i can figure that
out more um i know that it's not just
like money she worries about a lot of
stuff she's just like that kind of
person just worries about a lot of stuff
kind of like expects the worst all the
time and so like
if you know our car would blow up or
something like that that would
completely drain the fun
and then we'd have to like start all
over again so i think that might be her
reason why she wants more than that
what do you make
um i make 40 a year she makes 30.
so 70 000 a year
so if you had 15 000
that would be approximately three months
of expenses
and that would not drain your emergency
fund if your car blew up
right because i should just probably buy
like a two or three thousand dollar car
there well no i mean you can put an
engine in it for six or seven thousand
dollars and you still have nine thousand
left over if you had 15. yeah or buy a
five or ten thousand other car i to me
the here's the the broader question you
guys as a married couple who's about to
get married
is a great conversation to have as
you're entering into being with this
person forever is asking what are the
things that make you uncomfortable what
are the things that scare you out out in
the world what are the things that bring
you joy you should know those things
about the person as well as they can
articulate them before you marry them
and that's a good discussion around this
whole emergency fund thing and then the
other thing you do is um what i just
played on you there was a dr john loaney
trick
facts are your friends
you described a fear that the facts were
illogical
oh my car blows up it blows up my whole
emergency fund no it does not unless you
have too small an emergency fund or you
need to drive a porsche right it doesn't
matter well yeah i mean but i mean if
you have if you have 15 or 20 thousand
dollars in your emergency fund which
would be three to six months of expenses
in your case you wanted six months
minimum
because of her insecurity so so we're
really looking probably 25 or 30 000 in
your emergency fund and if you have that
i don't know what kind of car fire
you're about to have dude but that's a
pretty serious car fire so that doesn't
match up you know when you say if i if a
car blew up it would drain my no it
doesn't that's the facts don't line up
and so one of the things i've learned to
do and i didn't know i was doing it
until dr dolany taught me i was doing it
but that is if you lay out the actual
dollars and numbers in these worry
scenarios
it takes the power out of the worry it
diffuses the worry it diffuses the bomb
or it points it it highlights the one
that is a real problem that we got to
solve yeah and then you go oh now okay
that one yeah okay we're going to have
to get another job and work for two
years and well or do we buy insurance
for that thing there you go you know
because i'm not going to have an
emergency fund won't take care of that
that's right and uh so i gotta have
something to alleviate the worry but
most of the time when you give
numbers and timelines and details to
your worry
it uh it defangs the the worry that's
right it pulls the claws out of it
that's right and so you it takes the
poison out of it and because 80 percent
of what we worry about never happens
anyway dale carnegie used to say and the
other 20
you know let's divide it up into the
things we can do something about the
things we can't do something about now
we've got almost nothing to worry about
yeah because you can't do anything about
nuclear war or biden spending money you
can't do anything about that at all
except vote next time there's a chance
that's the only thing you can do but so
what you've got to do is get up off your
butt and exist in this inflationary
world that is real
so the best choice what can i do
something about what i can not do
something about so that's the problem
spend all your time watching fox and cnn
is
you you do all you do is worry about
stuff that they want you j ginned up
about right instead of going and living
your life
what a gift that would be huh wow
what would happen in america people
would start liking each other again
this is the ramsay show